-Higgins, you use Spotify?
-I love it.
-Yeah, me too. I love Spotify.
This is cool.
Today, they released a bunch of
interesting user data.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Because they have
like -- whatever --
500 million users
or something like that.
And they're figuring
all this stuff.
And it's fascinating.
Fascinating stuff.
I thought I can go through some
of the stuff just so you --
-I'd love to see it.
-Check out -- Look at this.
When it comes to
Spotify users...
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wow!
-Let's check out some more data.
Up next...
Next up...
[ Piano playing ]
-That's right, Jack.
-Here's another one here.
-Ooh!
-Finally...
A lot of interesting data there.
I just thought you'd like that.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Jim Parsons, everybody.